a boulder city man is frantically
searching for his roommate and his dog
tonight dylan graham and his friend's
dog arthur left to run an errand two
days ago and they never came back now
those who love them want help to bring
them home sasha loftis has our story
dylan and his roommate's dog arthur were
last seen here at renew oil before they
went off the grid completely those who
love them just want them to come home i
know that something's wrong it's been
several days since dylan graham vanished
in las vegas i've known dylan my entire
life and this is not like him the 30
year old left his home in boulder city
monday to pick up a paycheck with his
roommate's dog arthur in tow and he
hasn't been heard from since
now those who know him best are sounding
the alarm he's a really caring loving
down-to-earth person jessica bauer of
non-profit missing justice says their
frantic search is not unique according
to metro police an average of five to
seven people go missing in las vegas
every day and some of them are found yes
but every case is different she says
when men in particular disappear their
cases aren't always talked about so it's
important to pay attention to every
single detail if there's no signs
pointing to that they were planning on
doing this then there could be a real
problem as for those behind dylan
they're hoping anyone who's seen him
arthur the dog or even his white truck
will come forward definitely very
worried concerned so they can see the
person they love
home and safe again just come home man i
don't care if you have to crawl just
call me dude dylan was last seen in a
2008 toyota tundra with a six-inch lift
if you have any information on where he
may be you are asked to call boulder
city police or crime stoppers to remain
anonymous
reporting in las vegas tonight sasha
loftis 8 news now